He said that let's follow what is
common. So all religious speak about
prophet Muhammad. So Quran speaks about
prophet Muhammad. So what is unique?
Very good question. All the other
religions say that there will be a
prophet to come later on as the Bible
says you being a Christian and a student
of the Bible. I believe in the gospel of
John chapter number 16 verse number 12
to 14 Jesus Christ peace be upon him
said I have many things to tell you but
he cannot bear them now for he when the
spirit of truth shall come he shall
guide you onto all truth for he shall
not speak of himself all that he shall
he say he shall show you things to come
he shall glorify me that means all the
scripture Hindu scriptures pi scriptures
Buddhist scriptures Jewish scriptures
Christian scriptures talking about a
prophet to come a prophet to come a
prophet to come
Quran says this is the prophet on whom
the Quran is revealed. The prophet has
come. When you study standard one in the
school, the ultimate is standard 10.
When you go to standard second, ultimate
is standard 10. When you go to standard
three, standard 10 is ultimate as far as
the school is concerned. Standard five,
standard 6, standard 7, standard 8,
standard 9. Now you reach standard 10
and then you give the SEC examination.
Correct? That doesn't mean what you
learn in standard one is the same in
standard 10. You are getting prepared
for standard 10. So once you prepared
1400 years ago Allah subhanana wa tala
almighty God as Jesus Christ said I have
many things to say unto you he cannot
bear them now for he when the spirit of
truth shall come he shall guide you onto
all truth. So 1400 years back almighty
God our creator thought it fit. Now the
human beings can take this final message
that is the Quran. In all the other
scriptures the basic message of the
oneness of God is the same. The minute
details may differ. All the scriptures
say about one God. You have to believe
in prophets and the final prophet
Muhammad. But the basics is the same.
The details may differ. But Allah says
in surah maida chapter 5 verse number
three on this day have I perfected my
religion for you. Have chosen for your
Islam and perfected my favor on you that
is the humankind. After the Quran has
been revealed, nothing new can be added.
Nothing can be subtracted. As I
mentioned earlier, if there's something
like the Old Testament and the New
Testament, the glorious Quran is the
last testament. So what is different is
this tells you the ultimate version, the
final testament of almighty God. So if
there's a old testament and new
testament, the glorious Quran is the
last testament. All these religions,
they're pointing finger to the same
book, the glorious Quran. the same
messenger Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him. Other religions speak about Prophet
Muhammad to come. Islam teaches you what
Allah has revealed on Prophet Muhammad
and what has he mentioned in the hadith.
So this is the final culmination
for the whole of humankind from Adam
peace be upon him till the last day till
today and until the last day. All of
these are talking about that same one
God talking about the last messenger to
come. So finally they have to accept it
and you have to accept the message and
implement it. Then only will you be a
true Christian. Therefore I say I've
given a talk on similarities between
Islam and Christianity and I've proved
that we Muslims are more Christian than
the Christian themselves. Because if we
analyze we follow more teachings of
Jesus Christ peace be upon him than the
Christian themselves. You can refer to
my video cassette similarities between
Islam and Christianity.
Question from the sister section please.
Brother, I am Susan and I a Bible
student and my question is in your
lecture you said that about the death of
the prophets and in that Moses and
Muhammad are of a natural death and I
came across the Quran that Muhammad was
given poison from one of his wife and
she gives in such a way that if he is a
right prophet he must be able to discern
that he's been given that poison.
Sister said that I said prophet Muhammad
as the natural death peace be upon him
but she knows that the Quran mentioned
that one of his wives gave poison.
Sister here is the Quran. I challenge
you to show any verse in the Quran which
says that one of his wives gave poison.
Nowhere does the Quran say one of his
wives gives poison. There's no such
verse like that. Maybe where you're
getting this from check your source.
Whoever has told you ask him for proof.
See whatever I said sister I gave
references chapter number verse number
chapter number verse number chapter
number verse number I quoted the name of
prophet Mhamadas in the Vedas I can
again repeat in Hindu scriptures
Christian scriptures I gave references
why so that you can go home and check if
you think I'm pulling a fast one you can
go and check where is the reference I
challenge you to show me in anywhere in
the Quran in any one of the 114 suras
nowhere it is mentioned someone is
misleading you sister hope that answers
the
Question from the mic here please. My
name is Vin Kumar. I am an artist. I'm a
painter.
And uh I was asked one question that in
your website you gave two reasons why
Mohammad could not have copied from the
Holy Bible or from the other
pre-existing sources. So you gave answer
that you claimed that there were no
Arabic translations of the Bible during
the time of Muhammad. But in Sai
al-Bukari volume number six and book
number 60 number 478 it says that the
gospel has already been translated into
Arabic by Varaka. And also second thing
is you said Muhammad was illiterate and
therefore couldn't have read books such
as the Holy Bible. But I'm not satisfied
with that answer because it wasn't
necessary for Mohammad to be illiterate
in order to borrow stories from previous
scriptures. Mohammad only needed to hear
these stories orally for borrowing to
take place. After hearing these stories,
Mohammad revised then and uh he wrote
the theological preassumptions and then
tried to pass them off as revelation
from God. The brother asked a very good
question. He goes to the website. So I'm
happy about that. Inshallah you'll come
to the truth and I believe you're a
Christian. Your name is Vin Kumar.
You're a Christian I believe. And
brother said I give two reasons on my
website. Not two I have given several.
You have picked up two.
I'll come to it because then you have to
read in context. These are not the only
two reasons. These are two of the many
reasons I gave. And one of the reasons I
gave that prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam an umi
as Allah says in the Quran in surah al
kabud chapter number 29 verse number 48
that we have made the last prophet as an
umi so that the blabberers will not use
that as a pretext. You have to agree
that between illiterate and illiterate
it is more difficult for illiterate. You
have to agree that do you agree or not?
More difficult.
more difficult
if a person who's literate for him to
copy is much more he can hear also and
read also for a person who's illiterate
he can only hear so at least you have to
agree with me for sake of argument it is
difficult do you agree yes mashallah so
these are points I'm mentioning many
this is not the only one point amongst
the many points this is one of them all
the others follow
point number two you mentioned I said
that no Arabic ific version of the Bible
was present and I agree with it. Yet you
quoted Sai Bkari volume number six that
var yes he had knowledge about the
gospel. Nowhere does it say that he
translated.
Brother, I challenge you. I challenge
you. According to Christian sources, the
first time the first time the Bible was
written was in the 10th century. That
means the Christian scholars don't know
their homework. The first Arabic version
of the Bible came much hundreds of years
after prophet. Yes. Waka coming from the
bunny Israel. He had knowledge of the
scriptures and knew Arabic.
Saying that he has translated it. He may
have written some notes but translated
the full Bible impossible.
Nowhere does Sai Bkari say that Varka
translated the full Bible. I challenge
you. It may say that Varka had knowledge
of the law and the gospel. May have
written some notes. If if if you know
Salman Rashi's book, Salman Rashni's
book also has verses of the Quran. I
can't call it the Quran. But Salman
Rashi wrote a book against the Quran. In
that book, there are some verses of the
Quran. That does not mean that is the
Quran. There are other people like I I
write a book. I mentioned certain verses
of the Quran in my book Quran modern
science similar to Islam, Hindu. That
book is not the Quran. You cannot say
Dr. Zakin translated the Quran just
because if you go on the website and see
Dr. Zakin I wrote a book Quran modern
science and I've quoted about 150 verses
you cannot say that it is some and
furthermore you said prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him wrote down and
corrected okay that's a very good point
now I have given a talk on Bible and
Quran in the light of science and I've
proved there are so many scientific
errors in the Bible for example in the
book of Genesis chapter number one
itself it says that the world was
created in 62 24 days it says says the
light of the moon is its own light.
Genesis chapter number one verse number
16-9. It says that the sun was created
after the earth. Earth was created on
third day, sun on the fourth day. I can
go on and on. So do you mean to say
prophet Muhammad took this and changed
it? The light of the moon is not its own
light. It's a reflected light. Quran
says in surah furan chapter 25:61 that
the light of the moon is reflected
light. Quran says the world was scared
in six ayam, six long period. So you
mean to say Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam picked up all these things and
corrected. Do you think you're a
scientist? No, it was a revelation from
God. So go for my full talk just quoting
part of my talk and as though like you
will say that I will you hear my full
talk and then I said that even if I
agree he copied from the Bible for sake
of argument and then corrected. Is it
possible for a human being 1400 years
back to correct all the scientific
errors? Means what is wrong he
corrected? It's impossible.
Impossible. So this proves that it was
not his work. It was the work of the
creator almighty God. Hope that answers
the question.
Question from the center mic please. Yes
sir. My name is Y Rusher or Sridaris.
I'm principal of uh BD college but I
studied different religions sir uh
including Bible and Quran hadith and all
these things and I have been trying to
truth and I learned namaz and I was
doing sir in one of the hadith
uh prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he asks a Syrian not to diverge
his faith and say laillah
the times were such
But nowadays
because it is the herbal disease our
psychological implications and also
social implications and other things or
past
is there any concession
uh for uh people who want to follow uh
Islam and also uh some of the things
given by tawo physics I visit Capra and
Stephven Hawkings history of time. uh
there are so many galaxies and other
things and we cannot brush aside some of
the concepts like analak or aam brahasmi
doing five times namas or even can we in
our rest time follow this concept of
anal hak and as some of the people
please post one question a time we have
lack of time I'll answer your question
the other people waking on the
microphone the brothers asked a question
that he knows of a hadith that prophet
told a Syrian not to change his faith
not to not to say la aloud in the bazar
he was beaten the brother has said that
prophet Muhammad said don't say laall
loudly in the bazar he was beaten I
don't know which hadith you're quoting
in context there's a hadith which says
that don't say Allah abbar loudly not
lie lie la that is a hadith because in
the war when they hiding and the enemies
is coming don't say Allah abbar loudly
because that means you'll be exposed not
in the bazar in the battlefield the
other hadith say loudly so that it will
encourage the other soldiers so depend
upon the situation he does one of the
person in the battlefield say
it gives the
passion the love but certain times when
you're hiding if you say loudly then
you'll be exposed so depending upon
different situation different things are
there your main question was that can we
follow Islam and other things like
Socrates or some other people or from
other scientists including anak as far
as following anything else with Islam if
it doesn't go against the Quran and the
Sai had no problem if it matches with
the Quran and Sai had it should be
follows if anything else whether X Y or
Zed whether science geography history
whether Hinduism Christianity Judaism
say something which is also mentioned in
the Quran, it becomes the f for you to
follow. If it says something which is
not mentioned in the Quran and does not
go against the Quran, you can follow it.
Muba optional. But if it says something
which is against the Quran, it is haram.
It is prohibited. Three different
strategies, three different ways.
Regarding a question, Islam believes in
five times salah. Does it believe in
becoming one with God? It is shik. It is
against you. You can't say I believe in
and you believe in more than one God.
You believe in and saying I will become
one with God. It is opposite. So anyone
who believes in that becoming one with
God,
he cannot be a follower of he cannot be
Muah. It's two opposite things. But
other things which matches with the
Quran, no problem. Which doesn't go
against the Quran, no problem. Hope that
answers the question.
Question from a non-Muslim sister. A
pleasure. Good evening to everyone here.
I'm Vakshmi Ayar. So I'm a Hindu and
truly believe in Islam. I believe in
Islam because I have got some proof from
it.
So when you said God is one, religion is
one, let me take an example of three
people. A Hindu, a Muslim and a
Christian. Let me take them together.
And if their bodies, if suppose their
bodies are cut down, what oozes from
their body? Only blood. And it's only
blood. Not the milk, nor the water. It's
only the blood. When you cut down, only
the blood oozes. Why do we differentiate
when we depart the body? The Muslims go
with burring and we Hindus, we go by
litting the fire. The sister says that
she appreciates Islam. She believes in
Islam and I congratulate you and I
welcome you to the faith of Islam
subitting her will to almighty God. The
question asked by the sister is that a
Hindu, Christian and a Muslim all have
got the same body, same blood, same
constituent. But when we die, why in
Hinduism do we burn the body? Why in
Islam do we bury? Let's analyze the pros
and cons and you decide which is better.
In Hinduism also they say you can bury
the children etc. But when you become an
adult most of the sects say you have to
burn, you have to cremate. There are
some sects which say you have to bury.
But let's analyze the pros and cons
between cremation that is burning and
burial. If we analyze in Islam we have
to bury. Why? Because today we have come
to know that whatever constituents of
the body is there the earth the soil
contains the same basic elements of the
body in lesser or greater proportion. So
from earth we come and to earth we
return.
Scientific
comparison point number one in cremation
we burn the body there is pollution. In
Islam when we bury the land becomes
fertile there's no pollution there's no
burning. Point number two, when you
burn, you chop down the trees, greenery
goes down, environment is being
uprooted. In Islam, when we bury land
becomes fertile, more trees grow, it
becomes a manure.
No chopping down of the trees. Better
for the environment. You know the
government says don't chop trees. If you
don't chop trees, how will you burn the
human body?
Point number three, it is more
expensive. According to Indian
statistics, every year crows and crows
and crows, hundreds and thousands of
crows, every day crows of rupees are
spent. Every year, hundreds of crows are
being spent only on the trees and
burning the body. In Islam, when we
bury, it is cheap, free. Point number
five, when we burn, the wood becomes
charcoal, ashes. In Islam, once we bury
in the land, the same land can be used
after a few years. It is forever you can
recycle it. The same land after a few
years when the bones gets disintegrated,
you can recycle. So logically and
scientifically if we analyze it is more
scientific, more humane, more better for
burial as compared for cremation. Hope
that answers the question, sister.
Yes, brother. Please announce your name
first. Asalamikum. My name is Mayor. Uh
I have to ask a question on behalf of my
non-Muslim friend. It's not my question.
He's feeling shy to come on mic. So can
I go ahead? What is your name? You said
Mayor. I am a revert but it's a question
on behalf of my non-Muslim friend. He
doesn't wants to come on mic. So if you
allow. Okay. Asalam alaikum to all of
you. uh his question is all the
prophecies that Zakarbay quoted u is it
possible that these prophecies were
being edited later on in all the various
scriptures of the world to u uh preach
Islam in a uh other way. So the brother
asked a good question. Can it be
possible that all these prophecies were
added in all these scriptures later on?
Can it be? Yes, it can be.
If it is not added, if the scripture is
pure, you have to believe it to be the
word of God. You have to follow Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. If you say
it is added, that means your scripture
is corrupted. You leave your scripture
aside. So if you leave your scripture
aside, the only pure scripture is the
Quran. Both ways you come to the Quran.
Heads I win tails you lose.
[Applause]
Question from the center mic please.
Okay. Good evening. I have one question
before that. My name is Mr. Ram Romesh
Kumar. I am from Nyapool. My profession
is pastor. So brother uh in this
occasion you are told the final is
Quran.
Okay. But I have one question.
In a bottle of yamama may people died.
These who by hearted the Quran there was
a few that Quran can be lost during the
Abu Baka time. And second
alkari volume 6 hadith number 510 says
but when three kaulifas third kaulifa
came he was fighting with harimia people
and the time this found all the way
reading a different qurans. So, Usman
written and another thing is Allah says
in Quran 15 9 says we we have released
and we got it. But here the Quran was
born and at the time what was the
corrupted why it was the corrupted where
it was the corrupted who is what the
corrupted when it was the corrupted
please answer me.
asked a question. He says when the Quran
says in surah hijar chapter 15 verse
number 9 which I quote in my talk that
we have revealed the Quran and we shall
guard from corruption. So when the Quran
says the Quran is uncorrupted Allah says
it's unadulterated. How come Sai Bkari
says that the Quran was lost at
Abubakar's time then third Khalif Hazat
usman came and he found different
readings and then how's it possible
brother what you said of Sai Bkari is
correct what Hazat Usman may Allah be
peace with him found is variant reading
for example in English language there
are different dialects same English
language a south Indian speak different
what is your name
an English man what is your name so
Hyderabadi has different accent I can't
imitate it Hindi style is different my
wife was telling me why don't you speak
Hyderabadi style udu yesterday
in Bombay we don't say no in Bombay we
say
so one of my Bombay brother said was
this yesterday
so here you realize that every area the
different dialect. So same way at the
time of Dusman in Arabic may Allah be
pleased with him there were different
dialects. What the prophet gave
permission was seven dialects. So in
pronunciation they made mistakes.
So when they made mistakes he said okay
let's finalize it
and we have to follow the correct
pronunciation.
So one of the reasons he did was he
corrected the dialect. If someone says
what is your name? The English man will
say what type of English is this? What
is your name? What's your name? American
accent is different. British accent is
different. Neutral accent is different.
Some are accepted, some are not. This
was one of the reasons he corrected the
dialect. Number two, when prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam when
the Quran was revealed, he had special
scribes and he told the special sabas
whatever was revealed to him, he
repeated it and the sabas wrote down he
rejected it. In that zed bin tab, may
Allah be pleased with him, he was the
main person and other scribes. Now many
of the sabas when prophet Muhammad read
the Quran they went home and wrote it
through memory. So now someone hears my
speech and goes home and makes points it
may be right may be wrong. It will not
be verbetim but if I tell someone and
check up okay I'm giving notes write
this read it again it's a mistake
correct it. Though the copy that was
kept with Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was verified by him when he was
alive. It was given to his wife Tapsa.
May Allah be pleased with her who was
the daughter of Hummar. May Allah be
pleased with him. So it was kept in that
custody. Now when people wrote on their
own from their memory there are bound to
be mistakes. So the Quran is not wrong.
Even though there were notes of some
people said now people should not get
misled. that is the real Quran. So he
said okay now I'll make copies of this
and spread it throughout different parts
of the world so that they will know this
is the authentic. The Quran wasn't
changed. People when they had their own
roots written down people did not know
whether that was 100% verbatim correct
or not. So man the third khalifa may
Allah be pleased with him he saw to it
that he made a committee of the sabas
and copied it from the original copy and
spread it in different parts of the
world and one of them is even present in
Tashkant in Coptaki museum today and if
you analyze it
it is verbatim same and today the hufas
even if you burn all the copies today
there are millions of hufas who know the
Quran by heart even if you burn all the
copies hypothetically Yet if these
people get together they can again make
the two verbbit in Quran. Hope that
answers the question.
Any non-Muslim sister. Good evening to
everybody. I am Mrs. Sutabascar. I'm a
teacher by profession. With due respect
sir I wish to ask you a question. How is
karma and moka defined in Islam and how
is it indifferent while in practice?
Sister as a question that how is karma
and moka defined in Islam? Karma sister
in the Hindu scripture means deed. The
deed that you do action it should be
followed according to dharma. And the
Hindu scholars they believe in a
philosophy known as samscara. the cycle
of birth, death, birth and death known
as reincarnation or the theory of
transmigration of soul. And they believe
that whatever kum you do, if you do good
deeds in the next life, you'll be born
of a higher level. If you do bad deeds
in the next life, you'll be born of a
lower level. If you do good deeds,
you'll be born like a human being. If
bad deeds maybe like an animal, like a
rat, like a cat or like a cockroach.
And only if there are no things there
are no balance of good or bad then you
get moka from the cycle of samscara
birth and death. This is the philosophy
of the Hindu scholars. But this is
nowhere mentioned in the Veda is nowhere
mentioned in the Vedas the highest
authorities. They do try and derive it
from Bhagwat Gita which is mentioned
Bhagwat Gita chapter number two verse
number 22 that like a body
changes clothes and puts on new clothes.
Same way a soul puts on a new body.
In the Hindu scriptures, there's a
mention of punar janam in the Vedas.
Book number 10, hymn number 16, verse
number four, five, pun means next. Janam
means life. Next life, we believe in
next life. We believe we came in this
world once. We only come once. We were
alive before. Allah caused her to die.
We came in this world again. We'll die
again. We'll be resurrected in the next
world. So we believe in this world Islam
believe we'll come once and then we'll
be resurrected raised up alive in the
next hereafter. Depending upon a good
and bad deeds we'll go to hell or heaven
swan. This is what the Vedas say. But
they could not realize the Hindus
scholars that how come some people are
born deaf, some people blind, some
people poor, some people rich, some
people healthy. So God cannot do
injustice. So they came up with this
philosophy of cycle of birth, death,
birth, death, transmigration of soul
which is nowhere mentioned in the Veda.
Even Bhagat Gita when it says you throw
away your old clothes and put new
clothes. Same way the soul throws away
the body and puts a new body once I've
got no objection. Once you die again
you're resurrected. But Islam has a
reply for the query. Because the Hindu
scholars could not agree that how can
God be unjust? Some people born deaf,
some people healthy, some people with
heart disease, some people rich, some
people poor. Islam believes Allah says
in surah m chapter number 16 verse
number two,
it is Allah who has given death and life
to test which of you is good indeed. So
this life is a test for the hereafter.
Now some people are born rich, some
people are born poor. The rich people
the Quran says you have to give zakat.
Whatever saving you have more than the
85 g of gold more than nisab 2 and a
half% zakat every lunar you have to give
the rich person may give may not give he
may give half he may get 100% marks may
get 50% if he doesn't give he'll get
zero for the poor man he doesn't have to
give zakat he gets 100 out of 100 in
zakat we
100 out of 100
in zakat therefore prophet said it is
easier for a poor man to go to Jenna
than a rich man the rich man will say oh
I don't have to give so much zakat I may
have to give I may not have to give if
he's the best maximum he'll get 100 out
of 100 for the poor man already full
marks so everyone is tested in different
ways some people are born healthy some
people are born with congenital heart
defects
we don't believe he's born with a
disease because you sin in the last life
it's a test for thereafter not that he
has sinned maybe it's a test for the
parents Allah says in surah anfal
chapter number 8 verse number 28
Your wealth and your children are a test
for you. Maybe Allah wants to test the
parents. They're very pious and he gives
birth to children who have congenital
heart disease. Someone will say, "Oh, I
don't believe in God." Those are very
good parents may say, "Yet I believe in
God." Allah is testing. The greater the
test, the higher the reward. Maybe Allah
wants to give them janatos.
Like if you pass a graduation, you get a
BA or a BSc or a BCOM. If you pass MBBS
you get doctor difficult to pass MBBS
than normal BA but difficult the test
higher the degree. So we believe no one
is born sinful. Everyone is born masum.
But in the Hindu philosophy of the
scholars not of the scripture they
believe that you come in this world
again and again if you do good deeds as
a human being bad deeds as a law being
this the Vedas never believe. And
furthermore logically if you analyze
today sister the crime is increasing or
decreasing increasing or decreasing.
Crime is increasing or decreasing.
Increasing is the population of human
beings increasing or decreasing?
Increasing. So logically if the crime is
increasing the human population should
decrease. It is not.
So that proves that this philosophy is
wrong.
And furthermore refer to my video
cassette similarities between Hinduism
and Islam for more details on the
subject.
Since we are coming to the close, I
would request one short question and I
would request the speaker also to give a
short reply. Please come. My profession
is training in yoga and public speaking
skills. I am Chandrakumar. Yeah. Good
evening my dear soul friend. J Nayak
just one thing uh I am basically Hindu
and uh I am have equal respect for all
other systems also and I could learn
some techniques of Christianity and
Islam from my father also. Fine. So I
would like to know from you and uh in
other systems
all are not universal only for
particular community and particular
segment Islam but the Quran is for you
telling surya subhaha 2420 some
difference for universal thing fine the
crisp of the vic I mean to the best of
my knowledge it is
survey it says but it doesn't say survey
hindu survey hindu no it is all the
human beings should be merciful happy
and pleasant. It is one thing and
another thing whatever the you are
describing for Allah in surahlas
like that in our Vedas also
verses 24 to 28
of yoga it is describing
He has not given to any birth to not any
person. He was not born to any person
and he is superior to even five basic
elements and he is at all the times
omnipresent that is ishwara. Whatever
the Allah you have given it is appealing
to the same ishwara what we call and in
Bhagat Gita since you know sloka 31 of
chapter 3 I mean uh karma yoga it says
what he says whoever follows my religion
all All the human beings Lord Krishna
says not only the Hindus who follow all
the human beings who follows my words of
Bhagavad Gita I am with them that is the
thing and to the best of my I don't know
that sura you say
we are getting late you already asked
three questions already please you have
asked one question the police is saying
the time is up we have to respect the
law other they say I'm not a good Muslim
I got the chit they have to end by 10:30
10:30 is already up I'll just try and
reply in brief all these questions
answered on the site you can go to my
video cassettes I'll give you a copy of
similarity Islam and Hinduism the
brother said I'll answer in short for
more details refer to my other cassettes
the brother said that even Hinduism says
that suk for whole of humanity brother I
said that whenever the scriptures came
it came for that time and for those
people that mean suk for whole of
humanity of that time
of that time not till eternity otherwise
Your Hindu scripture wouldn't have said
there is a rishi to come. If everything
was mentioned in the Vedas, why will the
Veda say Antimishi will come for what?
If the Veda has mentioned all the truth,
why will they say one moreishi going to
come for what? So this proves that the
Veda did say about human being but for
that time it doesn't say for the whole
of humanity forever. So all the
scriptures when they say another is
going to come that means he's going to
come to say something else. In the Quran
it says prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam is the last messenger
after him no one will come. If anyone
says I get a I get a revelation today he
requires a psychiatrist.
Messenesship is over. Coming to other
question you said that your second and
third question. Yvea said god is one you
should not worship him etc. I agree with
it. That's what I said. So what is the
question? But do you worship such a god?
You said you believe in kulawat. God is
one who's not begotten who has got no
image. There's nothing like him. So I am
asking you yes I believe in that. Do you
believe in such a god? So the moment you
give a idol to god that means it is
going against your veda and as I
mentioned earlier it's clearly mentioned
in the satara of panishad chapter number
four verse number 19 and by chapter
number 30 to verse number three
of that god there is no pratima there is
no statue there is no idol. There is no
image, there's no photograph, there's no
sculpture. You believe this and worship
such a god like the four criteria of
suras, then you're worshiping the true
god. Otherwise, it's a false god. Hope
that answers the question.
Alhamdulillah.
[Applause]
[Music]
Salah.